Ice cream is a super food if done correctly,
and it's the sort of food that I will only make from scratch
because it requires nutrient dense ingredients
straight from the source.
Three raw egg yolks from my backyard chicken raised on pasture,
3 cups of raw cream,
and a touch of maple sugar and vanilla is all it takes
and I whisk this up in just a few minutes.
I carefully pour this into a frozen ice cream bowl
that churns for about 20 minutes
until the cream has turned into ice cream.
It's delicious and soft at this point,
but I want my husband to be able to enjoy it too,
so I put it in the freezer to firm up
while I make my chocolate chip cookie dough.
I start by freshly milling my primitive,
regeneratively grown wheat berries
so I have a truly whole wheat flour,
which lowers the glycemic
load and rate at which carbohydrates are absorbed
to a more gradual release of glucose into the bloodstream.
This cookie dough is slightly sweetened with 4
tablespoons of low glycemic coconut sugar
and I add a few good ingredient chocolate chunks
that I first coarsely chop
before kneading with my hands into the dough.
Next, I make small little balls of cookie
and line a baking sheet with unbleached Parchment paper
so that I can first freeze the cookie dough.
This prevents it from sticking when storing in the freezer.
Finally, I remove my homemade vanilla Ice cream from the freezer
and let it soften up for about 25 minutes before scooping into it.
Homemade ice cream doesn't have gums,
thickeners, and stabilizers,
so this is an important step.
The cookie dough is the final edition.
This was literally my favorite ice cream growing up,
so to be able to make it in a super food way for my family
is truly a blessing.
Oh, it's so mouth watering